SIX GOALS ON 17 SHOTS IN THE
OPENING 20 MINUTES.
BUT AT SHARK "D" IS STILL HANKED
BY ERIK KARL
PLAY.
>> Larry: NEDELJKOVIC CALLED ON
RIGHT AWAY. NUMBER 73.
THE SHARKSE.
>> Larry: A WAKE-UP CALL FOR THE
VET RON TO GET HIS TEAM BACK LI.
AND JUST A SMART GOAL THUS FAR.
OAL, SCORES!
A SHORT LEFT
THINK CREATING TURNOVERS AND
SEWELLER EARLY ON THEGAIN.
GAME.
>> Ken: THAT WILL TAKE THE HEAT
>> Larry: ONE OF THE TWO
DEFENSEMEN WE SPOKE OF PRIOR TO
THIS GAME.
THING TO DO WHEN MORE THE SEEING
A LOT  TRY, FABBRI TO
RASMUSSEN.
STOPPEPE
FOR FALSIFYING A
BURNS.
>> Larry: STRONG POSITION BUYING
DETROIT IN THEIR OWN ZONE ON THG
A SHORTHANDED TALLY. POINT. GET.
SENT IN BY BY WHA PASS TO
RO
>> Larry: WILL PAY OFF RAYMOND
JUST A GREAT PASS TO THE FLYING
LARKIN WHO
I WANT SEND, FABBRI POSITION, TE
PUCK COMES OUT IN THE LOT AREA,.
BACK TO LEDDY.